so I wanted to create this quick video
to really emphasize that grass-fed beef
is not the same as grass-finished beef
there's a really important difference
the reason why certain farmers do grains
to finish or fat in their cattle is
because it's very difficult to fatten a
cattle on grass grain finished beef
takes between 10 to 14 months ok
grass-finished beef could take up to 30
months in fact the company us wellness
meats if you look on their website they
actually grow their cattle for 30 months
and by the way I don't get any kickbacks
from us wellness meats I don't get any
discounts I just think they're a really
good company and I do recommend them so
just because something says it's
grass-fed doesn't mean it's grass
finished it has to say it's grass
finished because if it doesn't say it's
grass finished its grain finished ok and
they're gonna use GMO grains unless it
says organic so that would be the big
difference is the time it takes to grow
and also the cows exposure to the
chemicals in the genetically modified
grains the other problem with the grain
finishes these cows have a lot of
problems digestive why's they get a lot
of gas ten times more acid in their
intestines they have incomplete
fermentation so they have a lot more
digestion and this is probably why they
use more antibiotics cows that are grass
fed and grass finished have a lot less
problems with their digestive system
because a cow is was designed to consume
grass one less point
Organic doesn't mean grass fed or grass
finished ok two completely different
things organic means without pesticides
without hormones without antibiotics so
most products that are grass-finished
are organic but some aren't
I just want to increase your awareness
of that alright there was my quick video
on the difference between these two
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications